this morning we are bringing you a CBS
News and stations initiative called kids
in crisis it focuses on the Mental
Health crisis America's young people are
facing there's an alarming new CDC
survey of high school students finding
42 percent of them feel sadness or
hopelessness and describe it as
persistent tomorrow as part of our
initiative CBS own stations all across
the country are going to exclusively
stream the documentary connecting the
dots exploring This Global youth Mental
Health crisis and in this movie young
people talk candidly about their mental
health struggles and we warn you in the
preview you are about to show are about
to see a wool show teens do talk about
Suicidal Thoughts
I cared so much about what everyone saw
not how I felt but what everyone saw
and I remember I tried to take my own
life when I was in eighth grade and I
remember looking at myself and thinking
I hate myself like I just had this
why do I have to be this person
other people your age are going to the
same exact thing and it's so overlooked
that like I feel like we just all need
to get together and talk about it more
oh that person is doing okay and oh you
know she's fine or whatever but
people need to hear the truth that most
kids our age are not fine
with us now is Jamie Howard a senior
clinical psychologist at the child MIND
Institute
um thank you very much for being here uh
it's such a high stakes topic uh so many
parents are invested and I think one of
the big questions is just what is
causing this increase in distress among
young people
since is a risk factor because of the
interplay between hormones and the
developing brain but in addition to that
we now have a layer of the pandemic
which caused a great deal of social
isolation and increased Reliance on
social media for kids to connect with
other kids part of the task of of
adolescence is to develop an identity to
figure out who am I and that gets really
complicated when social media is your
primary way of interacting in the world
and one in three high school girls
according to the CDC say they have
seriously considered attempting suicide
I mean that's a shocking presentation
and it's an increase in 60 percent from
over the past 10 years what's behind
that so again we think that in part it's
social media and the pandemic but it's
also more than that it's it's the
culture in which we live so kids these
days are exposed to vast amounts of
information that they weren't when we
were kids so I had to actually look for
information in a newspaper they just
open up their social media and and you
know they see global warming they see
school shootings they see all sorts of
intense information that their their
brains and their development isn't quite
ready to synthesize on their own what
struck me about this Dr Jamie is that
it's Global it's all over the world and
child after child would say I need help
child after child would say I've thought
about it boys and girls boys and girls
and I think one of the things that I
thought was so important the documentary
is that they stress time and time again
no matter how dark it gets no matter how
deep you go in that rabbit hole the sun
really does come out and you really can
get through it but when you're in the
middle of it use one person said I just
wanted the pain to stop I didn't really
want to die but I just wanted the pain
to stop how do you break through when
someone is feeling that low and that
dark that's a good question yes what we
want to do is make sure that kids have
access to good treatment these
treatments are very effective everything
that these kids are talking about
medication but we're talking about
Psychotherapy and Medicine actually so
for mild to moderate to depression or
anxiety Psychotherapy alone is a very is
a very effective intervention and then
when it becomes more severe it's the
combination of the two medicine and
Psychotherapy that we recommend so
there's a treatment called for example
DBT that is highly effective for
treating teens who have suicidal
ideation is what we call it thinking
about suicide and depressive symptoms
it's a really active treatment where
they learn skills so that when they're
distressed they can call up their
therapist for a crisis call and then
they can get like a reminder in that
moment this is how you can cope with
this we can get through this moment I
saw a clip of a kid getting bullied and
it was floating around the school and
then from there went to the town the
city then the clip went viral all over
the world social media has its benefits
but some of the negatives is that these
things can magnify a moment that is
already embarrassing when we were
younger something might happen a fight
might break out maybe
seems to be unbearable at times for
these kids so how important is it for
parents to know what social media is
doing to our children such a good point
it's so important for parents to stay
connected to their teens teens don't
always love to stay connected to their
parents it's a time when they want more
Independence and yet do your very best
to lean in and take advantage of natural
opportunities teens tend to be night
owls so stay up a little bit later try
not to go to sleep before them because
that's when their guard is down that's
when they might be more willing to talk
try to talk to them when you're doing
sort of a parallel activity driving
together like clearing the table after
dinner with less eye contact so that it
doesn't feel like so much intensity on
them that's when we can get a little bit
a little informal yes orange formal
taking advantage of natural
opportunities to connect with them so
teens are always looking at their
parents and their parents are going to
freak out about something right you
don't want to be the parent that freaks
out but at what point do you freak out
and say all right my kid needs help I
gotta intervene yeah well so you can
internally freak out but externally
reach out to your pediatrician your
school psychologist get them connected
to treatment because if you are anxious
at all it's better to go and seek an
opinion get an evaluation and find out
we want to err on the side of caution
because these numbers are so big and it
is should schools play a bigger role
here because so much of the kids most of
your time is spent at schools right
sometimes your peers are a great sense
of joy for you and other times they are
your your torturer that's that's exactly
right we know that mental health
utilization increases a thousand fold
when we offer Mental Health Services in
schools and that is the place to capture
these kids and give them basic
information about monitoring their
mental health all right so call just
Jamie Howard thank you very much thank
you very informative all right if you or
someone you know is experiencing a
mental health crisis can get help from
the suicide crisis Lifeline by calling
or texting 988 the lifeline is available
24 hours a day seven days a week someone
will answer